[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein super einfaches rezept
ich mache was die aus dem backofen mit
spiegelei und zurück der murat wird sich
richtig freuen
und vor allem ist es ein rezept was auch
kindern sehr gut schmeckt ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten für das rezept brauche
ich 800 gramm geschälte kartoffeln die
sind vorwiegend festkochend 200 gramm
zurück eine zwiebel einen esslöffel
olivenöl 300 gramm naturjoghurt der zehn
prozent ich habe ich zwei esslöffel
dijon senf salz und pfeffer etwas chili
200 gramm käse zum reiben ich nehme
jetzt den kaspar wahl also den cut käse
einen esslöffel gehackte petersilie des
glatt und aus dem garten sechs eier und
2 frühlingszwiebeln ich nehme zuerst
einmal die zwiebel die wird gewürfelt
und auch die soap wird gewürfelt zu dick
ist eine türkische knoblauch wurst de
moura sehr gerne mag
[Musik]
die zwischenzeit habe ich genutzt um das
öl zu erhitzen und jetzt kann ich die
zwiebelwürfel darin weder 2 minuten
anbraten und dann gebe ich so tut noch
mit dazu und gerade das tut wird für
eine minute mit an
die zwischenzeiten und sich jetzt auch
um die kartoffel und dem käse zu reiben
[Musik]
bei den kartoffeln habe ich jetzt gerade
die flüssigkeit ausgedrückt und jetzt
kann ich alles vermischen also
kartoffeln käse schon wir geben die
schlüssel rein da kommt der joghurt dazu
und ich freue mich dass gleich alles mit
den händen dem joghurt ritz cremig
rühren senf dazu und natürlich auch salz
pfeffer und chili und da müsse jetzt nur
aufpassen nicht zu sehr zu wissen denn
das zurück ist ja schon salzig
jetzt noch die sec und zwiebelwürfel mit
rein und dann alles gut durchmischen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier eine große
auflaufform und die fette ich entweder
nimmt er jetzt fakten spray oder zum
beispiel was da kommt jetzt die gesamte
masse rein und kann schon mal in den
backofen
[Musik]
so sieht der rest die auf laufe jetzt
aus jetzt kommen aber noch die eier
ich nehme jetzt einfach eine kleine
schüssel ihr könnt auch ein glas nehmen
und da kommen jetzt sechs vertiefungen
rein also ein bisschen rein drücken
jetzt schlagen aber ich mache jetzt
nicht direkt hier rein ich mag es immer
ganz gerne wenn man die eier vorher in
der separate schüssel gibt so hat man
auch keine gefahr dass zum beispiel
eierschale rein kommt und dann
vorsichtig rein gleiten lassen
[Musik]
jetzt darf der auflauf nochmal in den
backofen bis das eis stockt und dann
immer gleich sehr wir bereits kannst du
die offene tür öffnen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der rest auch noch fertig und
ich habe ihn auch schon angeschnitten
vorher mit den frühlingszwiebeln und der
petersilie bestreut was auch ganz gut
passen würde wer zum beispiel
schnittlauch und ich find's ganz schön
wenn es ein damit noch ein bisschen
flüssig ist das muss man natürlich mögen
meine mama markt flüssig ist gar nicht
aber ich habs jetzt noch ein bisschen
warm gestellt
wegen ihren fotos daher ist es nicht
flüssig aber ihr seht hier richtig schön
vor allem sind die kartoffeln schönwald
und sein wird sich murat mir das auch
richtig gut schmecken
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
dann geht auf meinem blog auch sallys -
blog.de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau
schreibt mir mal wie euch dieses rezept
gefallen hat und ich wünsche euch jetzt
schon mal einen guten appetit
bis zu rechnen müsst ihr probieren
aber das ist meine
[Musik]